correspondant en ukraine d'univers craag
bonjour gulliver vous vous trouvez à 200
km au sud-ouest de kiev quelle est la
situation guy l'hiver là où vous vous
trouvez
alors je suis dans un village de 400
habitants assez loin de toute cible
stratégique et pourtant on sent la
guerre ici on sent la motivation des
gens et la mobilisation de la population
locale il y a eu des tirs non loin d'ici
on pense que c'est une base militaire à
une vingtaine kilomètres qui est
peut-être cibler une requête a été
abattu par les forces iraniennes fière
d'eux assure un village voisin et cela
encore plus calmes anisé la population
locale on a vu les gens un peu partout
mettre en place des barricades
construire des sceaux de banker est
aussi préparer des molotovs et des
cocktails molotov excusez moi même dans
le village où je suis des gens sont en
train de préparer des cocktails molotov
en ce moment ainsi que des blindages
pour l'armée il y as l'impression d'une
sorte de mobiles mobilisation totale de
la population même ici aux zones rurales
pour être prêt si jamais les forces
russes essaient de venir ici
du l'hiver on en est à cinq jours de
guerre à présent cinq jours d'opérations
militaires russes en ukraine on évoque
bien sûr la résistance à la fois
populaire et militaires des ukrainiens
dans quel état d'esprit se trouvent les
gens avec qui vous avez pu parler ces
dernières heures
alors les personnes à qui on a pu parler
hier il avait le moral je pense il parce
qu'ils avaient cette motivé motivation
cette le sens qu'ils font quelque chose
mais bien sûr les phares mis les
familles ukrainiennes sont en détresse
sur tout le pays que ce soit ici ou ils
n'ont pas été directement frappés ou
dans les villes où il ya eu des
bâtiments résidentiels qui ont été
touchés où il y à plus d'une centaine de
plusieurs centaines de morts déjà parmi
les civils y compris des enfants c'est
une très grande détresse il ne faut pas
se le cacher il y as et un traumatisme
psychologique dont le pays aura du mal à
se remettre quelle que soit l'issue de
ce conflit mais je pense tout de même
qu'il y a un sens croissante que
l'offensive de vladimir poutine ne se
passe pas exactement comme il l'aurait
voulu les ukrainiens sont très fiers ça
se voit sur les réseaux sociaux du fait
que malgré les attaques très déterminée
sur la capitale et sur kharkiv la
deuxième ville du pays ces villes sont
restés aux mains des ukrainiens ont fait
état de combats dans les rues d'un rare
qu'yves ce matin mais tout de même il
est clair que la ville est toujours sous
contrôle l'ukrainienne même en étant une
ville russophones dans l'est du pays à
30 kilomètres de la frontière avis une
ville que bloody mary ellen ski le
président lui même avait dit pourrait
peut-être être prises par les russes eh
bien non cette nouvelle là c'est quelque
chose qui est de les y craignant à
garder le moral à garder un certain
optimisme mais il y a des mauvaises
nouvelles le venons d'ailleurs pour les
ukrainiens par exemple on a appris ce
matin que le père johns quetier la
deuxième plus grand port sur la mer
d'azov dans la partie contrôlée par
l'ukraine après marioupol et bien perdre
dans ce cas est tombée aux mains des
russes perdions est à l'ouest de
marioupol sur la route qui mène vers la
crimée on a souvent parlé de ce couloir
entre le donne basse et la crime et que
la russie voudrait ouvrir et donc il
semble qu'elle ait vraiment pas de
réussir dû ouvrir ce couloir là même si
marioupol est toujours aux mains des
ukrainiens il semble que la ville serait
encerclé cyber dans ce qui est plus à
l'ouest et a été prise par les russes et
on va suivre l'évolution de la situation
dans le sud de l'ukraine de très près
merci beaucoup gulliver nous sommes à
présent en ligne avec sylvain